le géopolitologue frédéric encel au
coeur des 100 morts de la guerre aux
presses universitaires de france
bonsoir frédéric encel merci d'être avec
nous en direct ce rêve t france donald
trump est ce qu'il peut être destitué
dans les dix jours parce que c'est un
court délai extrêmement difficile
réponse dans votre question ce délai
extrêmement court ça nécessite d'abord
une unv bien évidemment des
parlementaires ça nécessite l'accord du
vice-président alors vice président on a
vu que il avait évité effectivement
heureusement d'ailleurs
heureusement pour la démocratie
américaine de franchir la la ligne rouge
de la constitution en validant bien
évidemment les vols des grands électeurs
mais enfin il ira certainement pas plus
loin que cela
et puis vous avez une autre possibilité
celle il vient d'être évoquée par
l'intervenant précédent en l'occurrence
le maire de new york qui relève de
l'irresponsabilité mentale seulement là
si vous voulez c'est encore une autre
procédure et surtout il y à une
contradiction fondamentale
vous pouvez très difficilement accuser
quelqu'un les séditions il pour le coup
est ce qu on lui reprocherait en justice
et dans une justice de nature criminelle
et non pas seulement correctionnel c'est
la sédition extrêmement grave dans une
démocratie mais à ce moment là si on
l'accuse de cela on ne peut pas en même
temps l'accusé
finalement en gros d'être fou parce que
là on a affaire à un acte effectivement
potentiellement que c'est minable et de
nature politique
on peut pas jouer sur l'idée aussi alors
quand on entend certains leaders
démocrates je peux enfin à nancy pelosi
mais à d'autres également ont sans
véritablement dans entendu tout à
l'heure le maire de new york on sent
véritablement une volonté d'en finir
avec ce mandat avant l'échéance prévue
sur les modalités de la procédure de
destitution est ce qu'il est possible
d'accélérer les choses ou pas du tout
libérer manière artificielle un banks et
c'est long en général ça prend plusieurs
mois alors sauf effectivement à
convoquer le 25e les canaux 25e
amendement et la faire un petit peu
comme on l'avait fait en france avec
paul deschanel
ces derniers ont considéré que ce garçon
est devenu d'irresponsable et
effectivement lui retirer dans l'est
dans les heures qui viennent en quelque
sorte la possession de ses prérogatives
et notamment le bouton rouge
je veux dire franchement en dix jours ça
me paraît extraordinairement difficile
et c'est d'autant plus vrai qu'une
partie des républicains n'acceptera pas
d'aller jusqu'au bout d'aller jusque là
pourquoi parce que dans deux ans eh bien
on est déjà on a déjà affaire à des
élections légistatives et on a bien joué
qu'une grande partie de l'électorat
républicain et les sympathisants
républicains était resté quand même
proche alors peut-être pas jusqu'au bout
mais en tout cas au moins jusqu'au 5 ou
6 janvier proche de 2 de 3 mais en
réalité ce que l'on appelle aussi essaye
de faire ce que démocrates essaient de
faire c'est d'empêcher de malte rome de
se représenter à la résidence dont
quatre ans parce que si il est destitué
que ce soit les gens pour des raisons
non pas le médical ou pour des raisons
criminelles
et bien il ne pourra pas
institutionnellement sur représentés
donc vous vous y faisait allusion tout à
l'heure dans le texte de l'hymne qui
chantent
qu'est ce qu'il contient ce texte
concrètement pour justement empêcher
donald trump de se représenter 28
pendant quatre ans concrètement c'est la
violation de la constitution
alors est ce que dans la constitution
américaine qui est très courte qui est
très très pédagogique d'ailleurs à
certains égards est-ce qu'il ya quelque
chose
le donald trump aurait transgressé cette
possible ses preuves en tout cas c'est
jouable
entre guillemets d'un point de vue
politique ou juridique mais encore une
fois sa demande davantage qu'une poignée
de deux jours et encore une fois c'est
la sphère de de l'appel à la violence et
est en réalité de la sédition parce que
l'appel à la violence contre les
institutions puisque le capitole bien
évidemment est le réceptacle les gens
c'est du genre surtout lorsque les
congressmen se retrouve dans un dans un
moment très fort du calendrier
institutionnel et post électorale pour
faire le recomptage des voix évidemment
on est effectivement je crois très
proche de ce qui s'appelle la sédition
est là bien évidemment c'est strictement
interdit l'importation a fortiori
lorsqu'on est président et donc garant
de cette même institution fait que
donald trump n'a pas l'intention de se
rendre à la prestation de serment de joe
biden dans son camp où s'il semble quand
même
est relâché et ce qu'il est possible
qu'il démissionne avant avant la fin de
son mandat dans les dix jours qui
viennent ou pas dans un train en
oncologie il a parfaitement droit de
fait d'abord ils peuvent démissionner
absolument quand bon lui semble pendant
ses quatre ans de demandes à ce moment
là pendant trois jours quatre jours et
bien le jeu il donne son vice-président
qu'il est toujours deviendrait le
président des états unis d'amérique pour
de plein droit de plein droit et avec
l'intégralité des prérogatives bien
d'autres résidents y compris le bouton
rouge
bon alors c'est tout à fait possible
parce que en fait ce président a été
tellement imprévisible et tellement
inconséquent pendant quatre ans et on
l'a vu encore ces derniers jours que
c'est une alternative qui est possible
ça changeait rien parce que s'ils
démissionnent maintenant ils pourraient
quand même un être et être condamnés
alors j'allais le dire en tant que
simple citoyen dans les prochains jours
pour avoir quand même encouragé la
violence et s'il était condamné même
même en ayant démissionné préalablement
et bien dont quatre ans il ne pourrait
plus se représenter à la présidence des
états unis alors on voit que quatre
jours après l'assaut du capitole les
tensions elles perdurent aux états unis
on parlait de ces tensions sur une plage
proche en californie justement entre des
pro train [ __ ] en titre up
selon un sondage plus selon plusieurs
sondages
un électeur républicain sur deux
soutiens d'envahissement du capitole
qu'est ce que cela révèle sur cette
amérique qui semble clivé aujourd'hui
est ce qu'elle est réconciliables ou pas
alors je pense que l'amérique brocélia
comme toute population qui vous comme
tout peuple et qui a connu des clivages
extrêmement dure et réconciliables c'est
là en ce moment on est dans l'émotion
on considère que ce qui s'est produit
est gravissime alors c'est vrai c'est
grave
notamment parce que c'est une première
au pays parce que c'est toujours grave
dans une démocratie qui se respecte et
les admissions une vraie démocratie et
vous avez raison de citer un chiffre qui
est important alors attendez 74 millions
d'euros taux si la moitié continue à
soutenir ce qui s'est produit au
capitole ça ne fait quand même que vance
pour cent de l'ensemble des inscrits
autrement dit les adultes aux états unis
et là vous voyez que c'est déjà moins
catastrophique et puis surtout il faut
absolument avoir à l'esprit que le 20
janvier il va se passer quoi qu'il se
soit produit au capitole il ya quelques
jours de cela il va se reproduire ce qui
se passe toujours de manière extrêmement
régulière presque lui les presque
mécanique depuis maintenant un peu plus
de 200 ans
aux etats unis c'est à dire une
passation de pouvoir est noté que la dia
sur tous les démocrates
la grande majorité des élus républicains
quand même la majorité du peuple
américain et toutes les institutions à
commencer par l'armée la police et bien
évidemment ministration soutiennent
évidemment l'investiture de joe biden et
reconnaissent ils ont reconnu très vite
sa victoire au mondial à choindez fin on
aura quand même et je crois c'est le
principal le une véritable victoire de
la démocratie et des institutions
merci beaucoup avoue frédéric encel je
rappelle que vous êtes géopolitologue
hauteur des 100 mots de la guerre aux
presses universitaires de france